YouTube Red, not mentioned in the main video,
is YouTube's second source of income that avoids the whole
advertiser auction by getting viewers to pay monthly to hide the ads and get access to exclusive content.
YouTube keeps the exact split of revenue a secret,
only saying that creators get a majority,
but whatever that percent is, that portion of the money collected from subscribers is divided among
all creators based on what percent of total time on YouTube their videos are watched.
Doing a very ballpark estimate,
channels with short videos might get around 5% additional revenue from Red,
and channels with really long videos that are watched might get 40 to 50% more.
It's worth noting that per view a YouTube subscriber is worth more to both YouTube and creators,
not just in dollars, but also in stability.
Their monthly payments are predictable unlike the ad auctions,
So, it shouldn't be a surprise if YouTube continues to try to turn more subscribers and countries Red.